squid game apparently there's a lot of
medical scenes in it i watched a few
episodes if you did it spoiler alert
let's get started
let me see
poor thing
i don't think i have to explain to you
why
eating someone's blood is a bad thing
infection disease
ah
got a sweet taste to it was he of
diabetes did he just diagnose him with
diabetes back in the day if you had
uncontrolled diabetes your urine would
have a fruity odor to it that's where
diabetes mellitus came from
[Music]
[Music]
didn't your mom ever teach you to not
get in the car with strangers
see i need an anesthesiologist right now
because i don't know what this gas is i
want to know what gas they're using if
you know comment down below
this scene here is really cool but
there's a few improbable factors
happening at the same time how do they
all wake up simultaneously at the same
exact time if they were giving a
chemical chemicals have different
excretion points in different
individuals i'm gonna have a certain set
of effects you may have a different set
of effects how do they all wake up
uniformly green light
red light
player 324
eliminated
oh
that's internal bleeding
medically
i think you and i have the same
understanding of what's happening
this old man red light why does he have
a huge smile on his face watching this
you know what just happened he tore his
atf his anterior talofibular ligament
just like me i actually just got my mri
done i tore it
if momentum's carrying you forward and
you're falling for someone to grab you
while they're leaning forward you just
have to be jack diesel
there's no way you're doing it
especially this guy with his frame no
shot
game number one in squid game
not compatible with life unless you can
get past a line then compatible
oh
she's diabetic when a patient's diabetic
they have poor circulation to their
lower extremities and you don't have
white blood cells going to fight the
infection that area therefore you get a
worsening infection again green which
leads to an amputation she had to be in
a lot of pain recently that's not true
because you're having your nervous
system suffer you actually might not
feel that you have such a bad infection
on your lower extremity will you be able
to treat her for it in the worst case
she might need to have her feet
amputated
let's keep her here for now and
treatment here is iv antibiotics and
wound cultures to see if the antibiotics
are appropriate
give me my money
this is an incredibly painful injury you
have a ton of nerve endings in your
fingertips in your hand that's why
you're able to do very fine motor
control two-point discrimination where
if you have two pins touching your
fingers you can tell the difference
between them even though they're really
close together so getting your hand
crushed like that obviously very painful
also you can't use your hand again it
would have to be amputated the rest of
it you can't just put it back together
like you can with a fracture jerk
that wasn't good form on the punch you
don't want to do one of these wide
things no because i'm boxing lately
hip kick
hip kick
rip kick
is it that hard
but did he dive is it
look at his bear hair on me i mean he's
must have done some powerful kicking
the one way you could die in that
situation is obviously internal bleeding
but what could be more dangerous is if
he kicked the rib the rib fractured and
actually punctured a lung he then had a
pneumothorax with a collapsed lung and
because that he wasn't able to perfuse
his body and as a result he died
again with the neck cracking stop with
the neck cracking i would now like to
welcome you all
to the third game my favorite game tug
of war tell me you don't want to be one
of those for halloween just tell me
when you're falling from that height
everything breaks everything splatters
because you're essentially going from a
really fast speed to a complete stop um
incompatible with life he's not
breathing go get that doctor didn't he
just like fall down a massive height
he's not breathing
is that a liver
looks like a liver
how about some ice for that liver
ideally when you're transporting organs
that have been harvested for donation
their viability after death varies
depending on which organ you're talking
about the heart for example probably the
shortest lived one four to six hours
ideally you want to keep them cold
almost like a refrigerator this fluid
that they're putting the organs in is
probably some sort of preservation fluid
to help protect the organs from the cold
that they're about to be put into i bet
i could do it
if you teach me a few tricks yeah you
think all this is so simple huh i saw on
the news doctors don't always perform
surgeries sometimes it's the office
managers or nurse's aides i don't know
if this is supposed to be comedy or not
if you
know a surgeon who is allowing their
office managers to perform surgeries
call the medical board call 9-1-1 call
somebody because that shouldn't be
happening we didn't even get full price
because it only had one kidney you can
live without a kidney you can actually
live without multiple organs lungs
kidney tonsils appendix gallbladder and
a few more that i'll mention in future
videos my doctor said counting is good
so i don't get
dementia or anything the brain and the
theory of if you don't use it you lose
it it's quite true muscles you don't use
them they atrophy your brain you don't
challenge it you actually start fading
the cow goes moo
so by staying active by keeping social
connections by counting who's around you
and doing sudoku puzzles that actually
keeps you sharper longer it's been
proven doctor said there's a
a lump inside of here growing every day
brain tumor you know not all brain
tumors are fatal there's some brain
tumors that can be operated on it
obviously depends on the type of brain
tumor and where in your brain it
actually is what's going on
fever is obviously a sign of infection
and a fever by the way is a good thing
it's your survival mechanism your immune
system works better when you have a
fever generally speaking if you're a
healthy person taking antipyretics
medications that lower your temperature
is strictly for your comfort not for
actual benefit we need to lower your
fever hold on
see like he wants to lower his fever for
comfort the fever is actually working in
his interest to keep him alive
[Music]
[Applause]
if you lost control over your urination
you're probably septic your altered
mental status your blood pressure's
dropping you can't get up and walk
around sir we have to play now we gotta
start right now
play what
what are marbles let's go this is a
direct symptom of ams altered mental
status feeling out of it disconnected
from reality i've seen patients say some
really terrible things to their own
family members even
oh
wow okay i know what she's about to do i
also wish she would wrap at least some
paper around it so she's not ripping
sharp glass with her hand
no just leave it in
oh no
this is terrible once you start piercing
the bowel you essentially start having
escape of bacteria into the gut and when
that happens you start getting an
infection of the entire abdomen you
essentially die without treatment of
course i don't know how she's gonna
survive like you just gotta put pressure
and hope for the best at this point take
another step in
he just ate that bullet like a champ bam
i hope he's wearing a vest
he just
casually popped out the bullet with a
knife that was a fairly close range shot
that's going deeper than just
superficial that you could just pop it
out like that's going deep into your
shoulder just this is so unrealistic
cells at work amazing anime reviewing
all of that down below several episodes
click here to check it out and as always
stay happy and healthy green light click
on this video
[Music]